[Aplausos]
[Música]
este año 2019 para mí es un año
importante porque marca un hito marca un
hito de un viaje personal que ha sido mi
pasión y mi obsesión durante los últimos
10 años porque durante estos últimos 10
años
me he dedicado a recorrer latinoamérica
todavía me faltan allí algunos países
por conocer pero las banderitas que
ustedes ven allí abajo son todos los
países en los que he puesto el pie con
un propósito para tratar de responder a
una pregunta que personalmente me
intriga pero también que me es difícil
de responder
viajando por latinoamérica he tenido la
oportunidad de trabajar con actores del
sector público con actores de la
academia con emprendedores con
empresarios y durante este proceso
siempre me he hecho esta pregunta porque
latinoamérica no es un líder mundial en
temas de innovación porque durante este
proceso tuve la oportunidad de conocer
distintas ideas proyectos
emprendimientos de empresas que
fácilmente podrían competir contra estas
grandes ideas que vienen de economías
más desarrolladas como de europa o corea
del sur de israel de los eeuu
y sin embargo de eso en latinoamérica
seguimos hablando de que somos países en
vías de desarrollo
[Música]
la pregunta entonces es específicamente
porque todavía no somos líderes en
innovación nosotros no solo los quiteños
no solo los ecuatorianos sino los
latinoamericanos porque es una situación
que he podido observar que nos pasa a
todos desde argentina en el sur hasta
arriba en centroamérica
porque es importante buscar la respuesta
a esta pregunta porque se ha vuelto un
apasionamiento personal porque yo creo
que la única manera de salir de este
estado que tenemos en latinoamérica de
ser países en vías de desarrollo que
tanto mal nos hace que tanto nos afecta
está profundamente conectado a la
innovación picando muchísimo lo que dijo
fernando diciendo que la educación es el
camino al desarrollo
yo creo que la innovación la verdadera y
profunda innovación no el sticker citó
de moda que nos persigue últimamente se
ha fijado que ahora todo el mundo ese
innovador todo el mundo es innovador
ahora es el nuevo título para ponerse
las empresas también se ponen innovador
por todos lados y sin embargo de eso la
realidad es de que todavía tenemos un
trecho un camino por recorrer pero hay
estudios que demuestran que la relación
entre innovación y desarrollo
socioeconómico es profunda es estrecha
aquellos países que son altamente
innovadores han generado impacto real en
sus economías en sus sociedades la
relación es bastante básica donde una
empresa crea un producto fuerte un
servicio poderoso que genera mucha
riqueza pagas salarios muy competitivos
a su gente y esa gente va y consume en
su barrio y por lo tanto la economía
empieza a moverse hacia dónde tiene que
moverse y cuando la economía se mueve
también empiezan a ver nuevas
oportunidades para desarrollo y nuevas
fuentes de progreso así que la pregunta
de por qué latinoamerica todavía no es
tan innovadora como debería ser debería
ser una pregunta que todos
y es parte lo que quiero compartir con
ustedes durante esta conversación
la respuesta fácil y es fácil apuntar el
dedo a esta situación es la educación
formal
cuando la pu se organiza un evento para
hablar sobre transformar la educación es
muy fácil decir sí claro porque es la
culpa de la universidad es la culpa del
sistema el sistema educativo está dañado
en la escuela el colegio la universidad
allí es donde se cae toda la innovación
y típicamente nos fijamos en una escena
como esta no la gente entra al sistema
educativo ahí están con su mochilita
preparados para un viaje emocionados
probablemente y durante el proceso se
les extrae fíjense qué fuerte está esta
caricatura se les extrae la inteligencia
se les extrae la disciplina y la
creatividad
[Música]
porque la disciplina porque necesitamos
la más poderosa de todas que es la
autodisciplina y al final salen todos
con su ponete el día de la graduación
orgullosos
luciendo un cartoncito
pero esta es la salida fácil esta es la
respuesta obvia que la mayoría de
nosotros tomamos sin embargo lo que yo
quiero dejar con ustedes de esta mañana
es que realmente no tiene por qué ser
ese el caso primero que entender porque
el sistema educativo está tan dañado
porque está tan pervertido y tiene una
relación profunda con lo que este
caballero aquí para quienes no lo
conocen este es uno de los
multimillonarios más importantes que han
existido en la historia de la raza
humana una de las fortunas más grandes
incluso si juntásemos en este momento a
dólar actual su fortuna contra las
fortunas de marck zuckerberg es steve
jobs de bill gates
el todavía saldría ganando saldría
adelante este caballero jedi rockefeller
es el padre del boom petrolero en los
eeuu durante su proceso de generación de
riqueza
rockefeller se involucra directamente en
la construcción y diseño del sistema
educativo de los eeuu
y él personalmente de su propio bolsillo
mire qué billetera que anda va a cargar
dona más menos 192 millones de dólares
de aquel entonces para crear lo que se
llama la junta general de educación y la
junta general de educación es entonces
el aparato el organismo diseñado y
preparado para construir el sistema
educativo como los latinos alzamos de
haber al norte del hemisferio siempre
con mucha desesperación y nos encanta
copiar todo lo que pasa allá resulta
hacer que latinoamérica absorbió una
parte importantísima de esta mentalidad
de cómo se diseña el sistema educativo
ellos lo hacen en 1902 pero hay una
conversación registrada de parte de
rockefeller donde él dice hablando de
crear el sistema educativo no quiero una
nación de pensadores
quiero una nación de obreros
mastica esta idea por unos minutos el
hecho es de que rockefeller necesitaba y
buscaba pues potenciar su línea de
negocio mediante lo que tendría que ser
el proceso natural de pues la revolución
industrial primaria verdad entonces
vengo en mi trabajo es todos los días
arman una caja y todo lo que hago es
armar una caja y si me puedo a penn a
preguntarme a cuestionar porque el
armamos así qué pasa si la armamos al
revés pues la línea de producción se
detendría cumplía un propósito para ese
momento pero el impacto que ha tenido en
todos nosotros como resultado es
fortísimo
qué significa esto bueno no sé cuántos
de ustedes ubican esta imagen acá esta
es la imagen del famoso trasatlántico
titanic que bueno no es una foto real
verdad que como todos sabemos rose y
jack si alcanzaban sobre la puerta eso
está demostrado científicamente
pero
es fácil preguntarnos por qué el titanic
cuando iba allí a mar abierto y se
alcanza a reportar que había unas bergen
el par en el camino en la ruta porque no
gira porque no lo evita porque no es un
asunto de que el titanic no vio el
albergue
el asunto fue que no le dio tiempo para
reaccionar y girar para esquivar ese
icebergs porque porque el sistema
educativo se parece muchísimo a un
transatlántico es un navío tan grande es
un sistema tan complejo hay tantos temas
aquí interconectados que es muy difícil
pretender que nosotros como individuos
desde este punto de vista casi romántico
perdón si soy un poco cínico pero
pretender que como individuos vamos a
cambiar el sistema puede ser un desgaste
más fuerte que todas nuestras energías
el sistema está pervertido y va a costar
muchísimo y probablemente solo va a
pasar después de que se dé con un
megabyte berg que cambie como estamos
acercándonos y diseñando la educación en
términos generales lo que es nuestro
trabajo es distinto es operar desde
nuestros espacios como individuos
piensen por ejemplo cuando añado está el
sistema cuando todavía seguimos
utilizando a la fecha
para describir la relación entre las
partes dentro del sistema educativo al
profesor y al alumno cuando ustedes acá
son profesores
ok se van a ofender con lo siguiente que
voy a decir cuántos desde acá son
alumnos bueno ustedes también se van a
ofender con lo que voy a decir alumno
viene de una raíz latina que significa
alumno sin luz a alumni entonces que
estamos diciendo es que cuando este
personaje gigantesco entra en clase y
habla con este grupo de seres humanos
ellos son los oscuros los no iluminados
y yo soy aquí el profesor el dueño de la
luz el que les traigo la luz que
perversa esa relación
qué terrible pretender que como
individuos incluso desde niños llegamos
a un salón de clases sin luz contrario a
lo que dijo silvia que nuestra luz está
allí presente en todo lo que hacemos
durante todo el proceso solo allí ya
entendemos cuando añado está el sistema
porque en realidad ahora se discute
muchísimo y ya hay una lista de 15
grandes empresas mega corporaciones que
dicen que el cartoncito que ustedes
están persiguiendo como estudiantes acá
va a servir de poco
y entonces ustedes piensan como se dice
en colombia esa platita se perdió
cinco años siete años de mi vida para un
cartoncito que al final del día puede
ser que mañana cuando vaya a google y
diga hola google quiero trabajar acá
todo el día y no nos interesa tu título
eso es secundario
nos interesa quién eres qué conoces qué
puedes hacer y un cartoncito es que no
lo muestra pretender que somos definidos
por un cartón es una equivocación
gigantesca entonces el camino no es
cambiar el sistema esa es mi propuesta
personal esta mañana porque hay que
entender que en el trabajo que hago
normalmente en mi día a día pues trabajo
con organizaciones típicamente con
corporaciones donde aquí me siento con
alta gerencia unos títulos tipos que
tienen toda una pared empapelada de
títulos no 2 mb as 3 mb as no no sé
cuántos títulos y el momento que tenemos
que hacer un proceso de innovación y les
digo listo vamos a entrar un proceso de
creatividad y de ideación
y uno puede escuchar los grillos
gobernando en la sala en ese momento
esta gente se entra a un estado de shock
porque tiene tanto tiempo trabajando
dentro del sistema que le cuesta salir
de allí para pensar diferente para
pensar fuera de la caja o dentro de la
caja para cambiar las cosas porque estas
tres habilidades de allí que buscamos
muchísimo en procesos de innovación
están profundamente conectadas a lo que
necesitamos hacer pensamiento crítico
puede ustedes alguno de ustedes decirme
qué clase tienen en la que se enfoquen
única y exclusivamente en pensamiento
crítico
difícilmente resolución creativa de
problemas mis maestros le llamaban hacer
trampa yo decía no no es que estoy
siendo creativo estoy hackeando el
problema pues resulta ser que no no es
bien recibido no lo enseñamos y el
problema es que en el mundo real tenemos
que salir a buscar soluciones creativas
a nuestros problemas y este es el más
fuerte de todos storytelling la
capacidad de contar buenas historias
cuanta gente talentosa conocen ustedes
con unas ideas geniales unas capacidades
impresionantes que el momento de tratar
de salir a vender una idea no saben
contarla no pueden transmitirla y por
eso estamos gobernados por un montón de
gente que sabe hablar bonito aunque
piense cosas que probablemente no
deberían ser las que nos bien
porque la capacidad de contar buenas
historias no ha sido desarrollada qué
significa esto que hacemos nosotros
bueno sólo puedo hablar hablarles de mi
propia experiencia solo para
compartirles mi propia experiencia y
quiero contarles mi viaje de desde allá
como dijo fernando desde el siglo pasado
yo también pertenezco al siglo pasado ya
en el 92 del siglo pasado yo tuve la
primera posición personal de decir yo
escojo que quiero de bachillerato no fue
como en el colegio que estaba esto era
el bachillerato en esa época una escogía
los bachilleratos o los colegios tenían
distintos tipos de bachilleratos y yo
quería estudiar informática ese la mi
meta en la vida entonces ya en el 92
escogí qué tipo de bachillerato es un
problema porque tuve que dejar mi
colegio mis amigos mi barrio para
mudarme un colegio que era el único que
enseñaba computación en aquel entonces
pero entré a estudiar informática y
resulta ser que me enseñaron computación
y contabilidad básica
nada que ver con lo que yo quería
estudiar salí del colegio y recibió una
beca para estudiar matemática en el
exterior y yo quería estudiar
informática así que rechacé la beca me
peleé con mis papás salí y empecé a pues
mediante tres empleos y un modo de vida
muy muy sencillo pagarme la universidad
según lo que yo quería estudiar pero
resulta ser que en la universidad
tampoco enseñaban lo que yo quería
terminé aprendiendo hardware y redes mi
tesis de grado
literalmente la tecnología sobre la que
la construí caducó al día siguiente de
haberme recibido
imagínense la emoción con la que recibí
la noticia
así que por mi cuenta aprendí
habilidades de programación porque hasta
ahora casi ninguna universidad enseña
programación para el año 2000 cuando
monté mi primera empresa resulta hacer
que todo lo que yo sabía sobre
tecnología no servía porque no
necesitaba solo pensar en desarrollar
tecnología ahora necesitaba saber sobre
administración de empresas necesitaba
saber sobre negocios internacionales
teníamos operaciones en cuatro países y
no sabía nada de lo que implica hacer
negocios en otros países y finalmente
tenía que aprender sobre venta
consultiva un proceso que casi que a
ninguno de nosotros nos enseñan y he
aprendido que el día de hoy todos
estamos vendiendo nos todo el tiempo
como mínimo a la persona que queremos
conquistar a nuestro jefe a nuestros
amigos a nuestros compañeros
desde 2009 lo que les contaba hace 10
años empecé un viaje totalmente distinto
y empecé a mirar en nuevas direcciones y
aprendido de marketing margen de tener
tradicional marketing digital tuve que
aprender de política pública que tiene
que ver con todo lo que había hecho
hasta este momento tuve que aprender de
innovación corporativa y finalmente en
este momento estoy empezando a estudiar
profundamente logística nada que ver y
no suena conectado lo uno al otro que
quiero decirles con todo esto para ir
cerrando que en realidad no es
responsabilidad del sistema su propio
progreso y su propio desarrollo el
sistema está dañado y cambiará cuando
tenga que cambiar pero es
responsabilidad de ustedes y dije es que
ya no está hablando acá de hackear su
educación
estoy hablando acá de hackear su
aprendizaje
porque el caso es que no dejamos de
aprender ni un solo día durante este
proceso descubrí que existe ya una
metodología para marcar este nivel de
aprendizaje y se llama el nivel de
lengua best learning aprendizaje en base
a indagación me interesa un tema salgo a
buscar los conocimientos al respecto
planteó ejercicios de aprendizaje
construyo testeo y finalmente comparto
que también era llamado a hacer trampa
en clase verdad fíjese busquemos
aprender en base a nuestros retos y
necesidades este es un método probado
esto no es un invento mío es un método
que ya se empieza a utilizar en nuevos
modelos de educación y que está
generando cambios importantísimos pero
no es no hay un profesor hay un
facilitador y ya no hay alumnos hay
estudiantes ávidos de adquirir
conocimiento cierro con esto
su propio aprendizaje
su desarrollo profesional y al final del
día su crecimiento personal no depende
del sistema depende de ustedes muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]